chimpanzees the regressive violent they
rip people's faces off that could rip
their arms off and they throw at
each other they also make for good kids
movies apparently chimpanzee so
chimpanzee is yet another Disney nature
movie that comes out every Earth Day you
know Earth Day is that day somewhere
around 4:20 now you know what it is
stoners and chimpanzee like the other
Disney nature movies they're pretty much
watered-down versions of the show planet
Earth
this time it follows two rival groups of
chimpanzees hey you know they're
fighting for territory and eating each
other's nuts I mean like you know
cracking nuts and eating them nut you
know it's the kids movie it's only one
kind of nuts they're one of the little
chimps a little baby chimp his mom goes
away or gets defeated or eaten or killed
or something they don't show it but
she's not there anymore then he gets
adopted by another chimp now chimpanzees
like an hour and 15 minutes long it is
not long at all in which case I have to
watch the movie going is this worth the
price of admission I mean it being about
an hour and 15 minutes of planet Earth
footage that you're gonna pay full movie
ticket price for the movie wasn't cool
it was cool seeing the chimpanzees do
their thing it's really cool seeing how
they have their civilization structure
there's a hierarchy a way of conducting
yourself it's really interesting to
watch
now when I say watered down it is
watered down for sure I mean you watch
the grown-up version of this movie on
planet earth and you're like ah the
chimpanzees are fighting oh this is
violent no they're eating each
other I see a little Timmy didn't
actually see that in his chimpanzee
movie there is a scene where the
chimpanzees kill and eat little monkeys
I guess that's okay chimps eating
monkeys fine chimp on chimp cannibalism
no gotta cut it out I'll still probably
freak Timmy out and he'll be like why'd
they do that and you just gotta be like
wow and chips kill monkeys they they eat
them that's just what they do good luck
explaining that to your kid plenty whoo
my hat goes off to the director and
cameraman cuz anytime there's a filming
crew who's like hey the two groups of
chimps are fighting so let's take our
gear go right into the middle of the
fight between the groups of two mammals
who can wishbone us with their bare arms
we might die today but hey it's for the
kids at home that's really impressive
hats off to them that's awesome Tim
Allen's the narrator and chimpanzee and
there's something about the dudes but he
has a good voice for narration as long
as it's not Oprah I am really okay with
it just when she narrates stuff
everything's way too dramatic yeah I
just don't like the way she carries her
words on the chimps go into the tubes
dad now
give me anyone else and I'd be more okay
it could be some guy who smoked since he
was like ten he's now 85 years old
commentating on the chimpanzee movie all
I know be like hey it's not Oprah props
to this movie so was it good yes was it
really short as in about an hour and 15
minutes long absolutely our kids and
adults gonna be entertained in it sure
is it worth the full price of admission
to see an hour and 15 minutes of
chimpanzees cracking nuts that's really
what the majority is they're looking for
food that's what chimps do gyms look for
food they eat them they sleep they wake
up they look for more food I don't know
but as far as educational films go it's
interesting I would say chimpanzee is a
good interesting time no alcohol
required so if you could be any animal
in the animal kingdom what would it be
comment below let me know me vampire bat
dude without a doubt they sleep all day
they're up all night so I pretty much
get to keep the same messed up sleeping
patterns already have you still make
time for those YouTube videos at night
as a vampire bat people think I'm a
vampire anyway so I might as well just
support the theories I'm knocked up or
am i and on Wednesday the 25th at 9 a.m.
be sure to check me out on the schmoes
know podcast we're gonna be talking
about all things Batman we're talking
Tim Burton Batman Schumacher Batman bat
nettles Heath Ledger Christopher Nolan
Batman we're gonna talk about all that
and it being a live podcast we will
be taking phone calls from you guys I
imagine they'll let you know what phone
number to call during the podcast so
Wednesday the 25th 9 a.m. Pacific time
otherwise known as la time be there be
square-ish and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more